when those temperatures soar the risk of
heat stroke also increases and it can be
deadly the cdc says more than 600 people
in the u.s
die each year from extreme heat the
recent heat wave in the pacific
northwest was blamed for nearly 200
deaths
and there are fears that the newest heat
wave in the southwest could be just
as severe our senior medical
correspondent dr tara narula is here to
show us
how to prevent heat stroke and i think
you know people hear heat stroke they
hear heat exhaustion
but what do you really need to look out
for well heat stroke is really the most
serious form of heat related illness and
it's actually considered a medical
emergency and if you don't deal with it
appropriately in time
it can lead to organ dysfunction and
death and so really it's defined by this
rapid increase in temperature to
where your body temperature is over 104
degrees
and that's associated with dysfunction
of your central nervous system
so some of the symptoms to look out for
nausea and vomiting
headache loss of consciousness or
confusion or dizziness
muscle cramping your skin might become
hot red dry
flushed and then you may begin to have a
rapid heartbeat or even rapid shallow
breathing and so
important if you are with somebody who
you think might be experiencing heat
stroke call 911
quickly move them to some place cooler
and get them cooled down with either
sponges or ice bath or shower to try to
get their temperature down to 101 or
102. well that's what i think is
interesting i think people don't take it
that seriously they don't they think oh
it's not a big deal
no need to call 9-1-1 but you really
have to quickly move on this and
is it important to drink water i've
heard varying things that maybe you
shouldn't give people water
right well in that situation when you're
dealing with somebody who may be having
an emergency
you don't want to give them anything to
drink because their mental status may
not be completely there but certainly in
terms of avoiding it
you want to make sure that you're
hydrating even if you don't feel thirsty
you want to drink enough fluids and you
don't want to drink things like
caffeine or alcohol or sugary beverages
those things might actually dehydrate
you
other things you might want to think
about doing obviously wearing sunscreen
because sunburn can make you more prone
to
being unable to regulate your
temperature ac
so important even if it's for two to
three hours a day
if you don't have it at home getting to
a public library or a mall where you can
be inside
avoiding cooking with ovens or stoves
that's going to heat up your
house so there are tips and things that
you can do preventively and proactively
well
that was the problem in the pacific
northwest so many people didn't have air
conditioning right yeah
well how fast can it come on tara it can
come on pretty quickly so your
temperature can rise if you're at that
point where you're about to
become a heat stroke patient within 10
to 15 minutes your temperature can go
above 106. and there are certainly
populations that are more
vulnerable so we think about the
extremes of ages
so infants and kids up to four and then
those over 65
those who are on certain chronic
medications like blood pressure
medicines antihistamines diuretics
antidepressants
also those with chronic medical
conditions things like cardiovascular
disease
and people who obviously have to work
outside so really important to pay
attention to those populations very
serious condition but it is preventable
dr terenaro thank you very much